hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay we got a
door here that's locked um I think I saw
another way to go back over here so I
don't know probably gonna be yeah yeah
behind this gate that was open
mysteriously open probably kicked open
by a monstrosity it's still daylight
outside
I'm just underground
whatever oh here we go
Oh give me some air oh okay now I need
to find a key of some sort I don't even
have inventory space for a key but all I
guess I'll find my way out yeah there we
go alright turn on the light go
that's dark ominous who wants some huh
huh
ah what was that Oh Simon tells us you
ah ah what's that huh that come from key
come on bat anyway to start off come on
oh no now the keyboards are mister I
can't even see what I'm gonna fog
douchebag oh douchebaggery just back
eNOS Oh fine what is open up ball I know
it's ladies boom boom a headshot a
Boomer come on boomer headshot never
games gonna laughs hmm oh oh come on you
stupid gone I swear to goodness you're
nowhere near as good as a Glock
oh no the lady there you are home oh I
said bum this lady don't know learn that
lesson
give me that I don't need some ranch I'm
good get more ammo
let me just sprint along my way oh shut
up
who's there huh oh I'm hyperventilating
whop baby okay take sure that one was it
all right just gonna get back to where I
was Oh air holes capital a holes
Oh get notice back oh come here come
here guys I swear
hold still there we go that's more like
it
what's that bomb what that I didn't
think that it it one shot him before but
I'm happy it's doing it now come and
come a flashlight ugh Ariel ooh
swimming it's so awesome
oh good think I can hold my breath for
10 seconds
ah c'mon what a loser and a wimp gosh I
swear I've been trying to give Simon
toughness lessons but he's just not
following and I was told that you could
kill the chainsaw guy he's got like
2,000 health but I don't know how much
damage my bullets I don't know how much
that is in relation to say other enemies
I don't know I'm not even gonna try to
kill not going to try hope it's going
the wrong way
damnit I'm on run out of air and then I
die and I must scream curse to the
heavens burger burger burger boo boo boo
I don't care Simon ask me how much I
care that you can't breathe oh I want a
nice one douche
couple seconds early okay oh I have no
tolerance for wimps
and I gotta figure out what I'm gonna
drop to get the oh wow I noticed that
the guy the three-headed monstrosity guy
he's sort of wearing like overalls Oh
get up there where it overalls or
something I'm gonna drop the shotgun
like right here the lip so o down there
that'll work perfectly because then I
can swim back all right let's go get it
and then run away I don't even I
remember I don't even need to sprint
away from this guy just need to run all
calmly and collectively are you in here
oh I don't even hear his screaming it's
even there goo mukha goo Moo goo moon
seriously what the heck nothing nothing
I'm not going back I'm not risking dying
god no way no how not risking dying
again because not going through all that
it's okay
please I love swimming so much mm-hmm I
hope I hope the big guy can't swim ah
that would be I would be nightmarish all
ladies come at Rebecca yes let's not
even joke about that cuz cool cool
no way is that cool yeah that was weird
I don't know why I didn't scream at me
or music changed or something like that
oh no you're not fooling me I didn't get
my shotgun but I don't I don't care I
don't really care about the shotgun I'm
sure I'll just fall okay your birds
again but I don't trust that not by a
long shot
I mean it's about time to day camp seems
like days not really helping sunshine Oh
what really ha ha Oh things are so not
gonna be okay bro so not gonna be okay
oh good gracious golly gosh I don't
trust any of this somehow this is all
more unnerving to me right now
oh oh oh hey yeah ah
would you come oh oh oh
do not trust anyone I can't believe I'm
freaking out so much when it's like
bright day revolver I don't have a
revolver I don't like any of this
none of this none of this I like I like
zero percent of this ha ha ha nope I
said nope I got a pistol too you're in
one of those shootie guys where are you
all right oh I see you oh good job
probably not heard you video aha oh yeah
got ya
pwned hardcore I'm the best still don't
trust any of this even with the monsters
you know like it's okay when there's
like a monster comes up and I'm like oh
it's the monster that's causing the
creepy it's not the monster that's
causing the creepy
for the guy go oh good Oh an assault
rifle um well I guess I don't need the
flashlight for now oh gosh Oh
something's gonna happen
Oh oh god I thought that was like a
figure in the window just shades ah God
not you yeah yeah yeah there we go
that's all hello how long were you there
nothing budge these doors won't budge oh
this is the last door oh come on it was
the last door oh no this is the last
door I should have I shouldn't lost my
flashlight ah
let me up it was like totally dark in
there I need to go get my flashlight
hold me Bros alright um yeah Saul rifle
I don't have enough ammo to make that
justified and I can't I need a weapon
that I can pull the off light with
oh okay is that come on do this
I shouldn't be freaking out this much
I'm a brave Oh easy is that
okay gliese you're giving me the right
pistol ammo ah hotel okay okay okay oh I
see I see you there you are there you
are
oh no do it one shot rub up here we go
to cha ok this gun is quite potent I
guess I didn't need to drop the assault
rifle it was right here I thought that
was gonna be like my home I thought that
was it okay it's fine it's all good oh
there's the assault rifle and well you
know what I'm gonna go back and get it
I'm just gonna get it cause it's not it
wasn't pitch black in here I don't know
why it was pitch black but whatever I'm
gonna get it okay good good good good
Oh still very creeped out buddy okay so
yeah I'll drop the flash really good I
don't need a light it's daytime out what
could go wrong
so many things could go wrong so very
many things
oh now it's not pitch black
whatever whatever
forgive me all these syringes but I
can't even hold them I guess I don't
need this many guns but I prefer this
many guns oh hello
but that up ronk ronk is so wimpy you
and your ugly face bycicle I use that I
don't need this right now
is this what I see you pop shot I see
you too umm Oh eagle eyes Oh can't stop
my eagle eyes ah missed you
no no no no okay I can't carry Glock see
what the hell all bed guy hello no nope
nope ha ha to the ground alright it's
not so scary everything looks perfectly
normal perfectly just I've never really
gotten a good look at this guy
not much to see he's og mo there jump a
back leap over the bike nope love done
insta Johnston done instead Johnston
don't say it three times you summon the
ghost of blood onions done Johnson or no
what have I done
whatever oh now it's dark um
damn it alright screw it
see how much need to reload in this one
anyway
I don't need all these guns ah I don't
even like the assault rifle fine
you got me now it's totally dark oh okay
ah I don't need the lantern of course of
course you just gotta trick me whatever
whatever
maybe that let's go let's pong some Bros
don't trust where is everyone
why is no one home why is there no one
anywhere I should expect like all these
doors aren't gonna budge
I shouldn't even probably try you know
if I were the game developers I wouldn't
even throw monsters at me because I'm
I'm now more settled than I was before
like I'm not as startled when there was
just nothing
when there was nothing I was making up
monsters in my mind but now I'm like oh
no it's just little monsters moving
along actually I gotta cut it here I'm
all out of time thank you guys so much
for watching and I will see you in the
next part bye-bye